this vacant parcel of land in Austin
Texas might not look like much but it
offers a glimpse into how a skewed
property tax system is worsening the
housing crisis in America's biggest
cities the lot has an annual property
tax bill of about 1.5 million dollars
per acre but just six blocks over this
luxury apartment building is taxed at
nearly double that rate cities all over
the country are littered with empty or
sparsely built sites some economists say
they share a common factor a tax system
that combines low taxes on land with
high taxes on buildings here's a closer
look at that system and the often
overlooked role it plays in the
country's housing shortage
to understand the tax system let's head
back to 701 Trinity Street located near
the heart of downtown Austin the 0.2
acre parcel is valued at over 13.7
million dollars yet for decades the lot
has only been used for parking and the
owners have paid relatively little in
taxes because it doesn't contain any
buildings Cielo Property Group owns the
vacant plot of land they did not respond
to a request for comment so traditional
property taxes perversely disincentivize
the kind of land use that we want to see
in our cities when you're taxing
improvements you're signaling to the
market that you don't want improvements
Josephine Foss is the executive director
of the Robert shakenbach Foundation a
non-profit research organization that
advocates for property tax reform so
they actually affect the way that people
use land or choose not to use land which
is something that might not initially be
you know obvious thinking about property
taxes when landowners improve their
property by adding a new room for
instance their taxes go up in some cases
these taxes can be as much as seven
times higher for a developed piece of
land compared to an empty lot
the basic premise of property taxes in
America is very simple it's basically
the government will try to figure out
how much is a piece of real estate worth
and then based on that value you'll be
taxed the more valuable your real estate
is the higher your tax
presumably the owners of more expensive
buildings would be able to afford more
expensive rates but some economists say
the system has an unintended consequence
it makes it easy for people to take out
properties and then just hold them until
the value increases sell at a profit
right so the Buy Low sell high but
without doing anything in the interim
including building housing
over the last few years Texas home
prices have skyrocketed in January
Austin's median home price was 525
thousand dollars according to the Austin
board of realtors that's a 36 percent
jump from January 2020. so housing
shortages have always existed in cities
like New York and San Francisco what's
really changed in the last couple years
is that you're seeing more of this issue
in places in the Sun Belt I think Austin
is really the textbook case of the
booming Sunbelt City that's now running
into all these housing shortage problems
because it used to be an affordable
place and now it's really one of the
most expensive places in the South but
despite Rising demand for housing
developers struggle to find sites to
build on developers paradoxically are
having a hard time finding land but even
those thoughts for law does allow you to
build often people just don't want to
sell Austin alone has more than 17 500
vacant Lots zoned for residential use
according to Altus group a real estate
analytics firm in Atlanta Georgia
there's more than thirteen thousand and
New York City has more than 77 000 lots
that are vacant or less than half the
size of what zoning allows that's a lot
of untapped potential if the owners of
all the vacant Lots in Austin developed
buildings to match the current density
of the city they could add over 1
billion square feet of housing according
to an Altus group estimate that's
equivalent to about 384 empire state
buildings or over 800 000 additional
apartment units so it's really adding to
this issue of affordable housing or
housing accessibility one solution
proposed by lawmakers comes in the form
of a land value tax this places a higher
tax rate on land while reducing taxes on
buildings in theory this system would
reduce the profit that comes from owning
a vacant piece of property so if your
tax code is set up that you can make
money by improving the land that you've
just been sitting on or selling it to
somebody who will that's what's going to
happen research suggests this type of
taxing system has increased building
activity in cities like Pittsburgh a
couple of Studies have actually shown
that they had more construction activity
in Pittsburgh relative to other nearby
and similar cities that didn't have this
sort of tax system still fairly
assessing the value of land for taxation
can be difficult some economists say
it's simpler to assess improvements
based on their income producing ability
there are also political hurdles to
implementing a new tax system one of the
big challenges in America is that often
under state law cities and counties
can't decide on their own tax system
they basically have to defer to the
state when it comes to building more
housing some developers say a land value
tax may only make a small difference
factors like restrictive zoning laws and
Rising material costs also play a role
in delaying construction projects
despite the challenges one city Detroit
May soon Implement a land value tax if
approved lawmakers and housing Advocates
say this could be a crucial test case
for the tax policy Detroit will be the
biggest city in the history of America
to implement a land value tax and it'd
be a fascinating test case on whether
this actually works in the 21st century
and whether others will follow suit if
it works out it could really change the
way Americans think about property taxes
[Music]